ils veulent venir ce soir le beau jeu
blizzard d'accord oui bien sûr je conçu
il ya mc dardon qui est chez moi c'est
mon cousin
il ya également matt damon ce avec un
matt damon we will matt damon à célébrer
l'un fleck mais ils sont à sarlat en
dordogne sur le tournage du film the
last duels ça veut dire le dernier duel
c'est un rire et scott brown celui qui
fait les blues ont léché
du coup je vous dis je me suis renseigné
il paraît que matt damon
ouais il va parfois dîné dans les
restaurants de la ville d'accord je me
suis dit est ce qu'on ferait pas une
mini d'arca pour faire gagner un beau
cadeau publique tap si j'arrive à rester
une lutte avec un restaurant de sarlat
en me faisant passer pour l'agent
américain de matt damon sera mal pas mal
ouais je veux gagner un cadeau venu dans
notre pays les rythmes où la foudre il a
aucune vérité loupé le resteront pour
trouver toute la nuit oui bonjour c'est
faux nez
oui oui bonjour stéphane et c'est john
stevens je vous je vous appelle pour
matt damon il était déjà venu manger des
burgers
il ya quelques jours oui voudraient
revenir manger un hamburger
oui oui c'est possible oui parce que le
dernière fois vous nous avez aimé dans
une petite salle il faudrait il aimerait
changer de ça parce qu'il ya eu froid
d'accord alors est ce que c'est possible
c'est bien stéphanie oui il va venir
tout leur il y avait deux amies
il peut avec onze personnes de l'équipe
qui veulent manger ils viennent avec aux
personnes de l'équipe
ils ont faim ils ont faim kiev après le
tournage
d'accord très bien c'est possible oui
alors je dis à ma psy vous appelle
[Applaudissements]
c'est fanny stéphanie mettre la table
appauvrissant canada et canon
[Applaudissements]
on appelle la calabre c'est une pizzeria
qui alors là je vais faire baisser matt
damon s'est pas attention attention matt
damon
je vous rappelle que matt damon et à
sarlat en ce moment et on fera gagner un
cadeau bien sûr cette période si on
reste avec six onces et sympathique on
va voir on n'a pas un smartphone à
l'aune de calabre la calabre oui oui
bonjour monsieur je suis déçu ce temps
du madame anne des systèmes d'armes à
dame en noir mat
il est dans le région où ce moment
d'accord oui oui on aime beaucoup le
blizzard adacore promeneurs sur damon
oui oui on aime beaucoup le blizzard oh
oui et le des quotas ce possible de
manger une pizza
il n'y a pas de problème ils veulent
revenir ce soir le mot juif isa d'accord
oui je pense que oui mais il n'y a pas
tout à fait valable
alors oui allô la calabre où la calabre
la calade je suis désolé mais c'est pas
madame c'est cyril hanouna
[Applaudissements]
lakhal ap
monsieur je voudrais vous offrir un
smartphone parce que vous avez été très
sympathique
oui j'avais qu'à damon t'es sûr sûr ça
va exactement manger une pizza
l'assistant de matt damon veut que matt
damon manche mais matt damon n'arrive
pas à manger au sein de sarlat donc ils
appellent le restaurant pour réserver la
table pour l'assistant pas du passé et
moi c'est un scénario à coup petit roi
oui allez juste passé mois sa mort ils
écoutent oui bonjour la petite molly
oui oui mon jour c'est le commissaire
feuillus de la drpj de sarlat jaunouse
appel concernant l'individu susnommé
matt damon qui est sur la région sar la
sienne oui tout appel aux grands oui je
vous appelle
concernant éventuellement une mise en
demeure puisque la personne aurait volé
les chouquettes
hier en milieu où l'enjeu éthique je
suis bien la petite borie oui bien sûr
là oui bien sûr monsieur je vous appelle
concernant l'individu susnommé matt
damon
l'acteur américain est exactement qui
est état mais que bana flic twitter je
vous appelle concernant
c'est de malotrus qui aurait commis ces
quelques échauffourées sur la raison
sarah sienne concernant un vol de
chouquettes
éventuellement puisque j'ai eu au
téléphone la drpj de ces heures-là de sa
commune à rien oui je sais que c'est
plus un commissariat mais paraît-il que
vous auriez vu des susnommés en dix
minutes qui se serait même passé devant
chez moi avec 12 sous quêtes la lune on
parle qu il avait vu le malade il avait
l'air un petit peu spéciaux jeux
spéciaux du tabac bon il y avait les
renault et détendue où tu es drôle et
quoi bon alors actuellement je suis en
enquête poussée au niveau de ces deux
individus puisqu'on les recherches
actuellement dans la région
apparemment il aurait volé sous quêtes
de type b des chouquettes de type b
c'est à dire à mes que des petits
morceaux de sucre sur la chouquette
obèses et comment je t'avais des
messieurs vous voulez réserver des
tables alors éventuellement oui pour
essayer éventuellement puisqu'il paraît
que ces deux individus sont vraiment les
chez vous dans les prochains jours ah
bon j'aimerais passer en filature vous
avez une table secrète non je veux une
table secrétaire du commissaire fueling
de la drpj soleil c'est à dire que ça
monsieur tulasne en patois lequel
[Applaudissements]
la petite grille
ces séries là mais en fait c'est si on
adopte un ton direct vous je vous offre
un smartphone et grâce à vous tous le
public à gagner un cadeau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]